Hallo Cari!
Hallo? Hallo, ich höre, glaube
ich, alles zu spät, Manuel.
Oh nein! Technische Probleme, jetzt schon? Direkt
am Anfang? Ich hoffe, es liegt nicht an mir.
Weißt du, woran das liegt? (Nee.) Nee. Ich
glaube, ich sehe … ich höre mich selber live.
Oh, das könnte na… ist auch gut, also, du
sollst den Livestream auch genießen heute.
Hilfe! Ich höre zu viel gleichzeitig,
Manuel. (Ja, dann …) Was mache ich jetzt?
Den Tab finden, in dem du unseren Podcast
live auf YouTube verfolgst. Ja, liebe Leute,
während Cari noch ihren Livestream schließt,
freuen wir uns, euch im Livestream unseres
Podcasts begrüßen zu dürfen. Wir haben ein
bisschen was vorbereitet beziehungsweise ihr
habt eigentlich alles vorbereitet, denn ihr
habt uns schon einige Fragen geschickt über
Instagram. Und ihr könnt uns auch gleich
hier auf YouTube noch Fragen stellen,
denn wir wollen heute über das Leben in
Deutschland sprechen und über Deutschland. Morgen,
ab morgen wird dieses Video auch Untertitel
haben. Das sage ich jetzt schon mal an,
für alle, die das jetzt nicht live gucken,
sondern erst morgen: Ihr könnt hier auch die
deutschen Untertitel dazu anmachen. Und jetzt
schaue ich mal, wie sieht es denn aus, Cari?
Ja. Manuel, ich höre mich doppelt. Ich weiß nicht,
was los ist. Wir haben hier
ein technisches Problem.
Es könnte natürlich auch an meinem …
Also ich höre dich live, aber
ich höre dich auch noch mal … Ja,
jetzt ist weg. (Oh Gott, es war
…) Nee, jetzt ist nicht weg.
Ist es weg? War es mein Fehler? Sag mal was,
hörst du dich jetzt besser?
(Hallo, hallo?) Nee? Immer noch?
Jetzt ist weg.
Ich vermute, dass vielleicht noch
irgendwo ein Tab sich versteckt.
Ja, ich habe schon alles durchgeguckt,
aber ich sehe, ich finde es nicht.
Ihr könnt uns ja mal schreiben im
Chat, ob ihr uns auch doppelt hört,
denn ich höre dich ganz gut, Cari.
Ob ihr uns auch doppelt hört.
Ja. Also sonst … willst du noch
mal Chrome neu starten oder …
Soll ich mal kurz abhauen? (Hau mal
kurz ab.) Und gleich wiederkommen?
Und ich fange einfach schon mal an, ohne
dich. (Ja, mach mal das.) Wenn das für dich
okay ist. (Das passt.) Also erst mal noch
eine Danksagung an unsere lieben Patrons,
unsere lieben Mitglieder. Durch euch ist das
hier überhaupt alles möglich, denn dank eurer
Beiträge können wir das hier alles transkribieren
auch nach der Aufnahme und ihr bekommt dann,
wie ihr schon wisst, das interaktive Transkript
zum Mitlesen. Und alle, die auch Lust haben,
mitzumachen: Ihr könnt auf patreon.com/easygerman
gehen und dann freuen wir uns, wenn wir euch bald
als Mitglied begrüßen dürfen. Und ich würde
sagen, wir fangen einfach an. Ich hoffe mal,
dass Cari gleich zurückkommt, aber wir wollen
heute natürlich … Oh! Heute ist der Wurm drin!
Ist ein guter Ausdruck. Eure Fragen beantworten.
Jetzt seht ihr, wie so eine Podcastaufnahme
abläuft. In den Aufnahmen drücke ich auch oft
auf den falschen Knopf. Eure Fragen. Ich fange
einfach mal an, während Cari noch nach dem
technischen Problem sucht. Es kommen auch
schon einige Kommentare von euch rein, das ist
super schön. Ich fange aber mal an mit einem,
einer Frage von Sebastian, der uns gefragt
hat: "Sollte man in Deutschland das Trinkwasser
trinken? Wie sauber ist es?" Eine ausgezeichnete
Frage. Ich weiß von meiner eigenen Weltreise,
dass das nicht in allen Ländern leider so einfach
zu beantworten ist. In Deutschland ist es aber
sehr einfach, denn das Leitungswasser ist
tatsächlich überall nicht nur genießbar,
sondern tatsächlich meistens sogar sehr,
sehr gute Qualität, meistens besser als das
abgefüllte Wasser, genau. Das Einzige, was noch
schiefgehen kann, sind die Leitungen im Haus,
wenn man in einem sehr alten Haus wohnt, zum
Beispiel in Berlin, dass die Leitungen dann
schon so alt sind, aber sonst geht das auf jeden
Fall. Ja, dann hat uns Sportsman geschrieben:
"Was machen die Deutschen am Sonntag? Es gibt
fast keine Menschen auf der Straße." Das könnte
natürlich ein bisschen damit zusammenhängen,
dass jetzt gerade noch Pandemie ist,
aber natürlich auch damit, dass in Deutschland
alle Geschäfte geschlossen haben am Sonntag. Und
tatsächlich haben wir da letztens schon im Podcast
mal drüber gesprochen, Episode 151: "Was machen
die Leute am Sonntag?" Kann ich dazu empfehlen.
So, Gustavo fragt gerade live auf YouTube:
"Warum bezahlt man lieber in bar in Deutschland?"
Da haben wir auch gerade schon im Podcast drüber
gesprochen. Das ist wirklich sehr seltsam, ein
seltsames Phänomen, dass man in Deutschland
dem Bargeld nach wie vor sehr viel Vertrauen
schenkt und nicht viele Leute mit Karte zahlen,
und schon gar nicht mit Kreditkarte. Es ändert
sich jetzt langsam, auch durch die Pandemie,
aber es stimmt: Bargeld spielt in Deutschland nach
wie vor eine sehr wichtige Rolle. So. "Was waren
eure Lieblingsfächer in der Schule?", schreibt
Nika. "Ich selber liebe Mathe und Physik und alle
meine deutschen Mitschüler hassen Mathe." Da kann
ich aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung sagen, dass das
bei mir total von dem oder der Lehrerin abhing.
Ich habe Mathe auch ziemlich lange gehasst,
bis ich einen unglaublich tollen Lehrer hatte, der
das alles so erklärt hat, dass ich es verstehen
konnte. Und dann fand ich Mathe auf einmal super.
Also ich glaube, ja, ein Lob an alle Lehrer,
die mit viel Erfolg das Wissen transportieren.
Cari! Wie schön, dass du wieder da bist!
Manuel! Ich weiß überhaupt
nicht, was passiert ist,
ich habe alles doppelt gehört.
Ich habe dann alles ausgemacht
und obwohl alle Programme geschlossen
waren, habe ich dich immer noch gehört.
Was? Sind wir denn vielleicht noch
irgendwie über Telefon verbunden oder so?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe dann ganz viel, ganz
große Schlucke von meinem Gin Tonic getrunken und
meinen Computer neu gestartet und ja. Ich wollte
dich gerade noch fragen, was du eigentlich so
gegen die Nervosität in einem Livestream tust,
und dann bin ich selber ganz nervös geworden.
Ich habe schon vier Fragen beantwortet,
Cari. Du darfst jetzt weitermachen.
Okay, ich bin bereit, Manuel.
Gut, wir haben gerade über
Lieblingsfächer gesprochen in der Schule.
Ja, wir ist gut.
Also ich … (Du.) Ja, also wir … ich
und alle, die dabei sind. Was war
denn dein Lieblingsfach? Und dann
kommt gleich die Anschlussfrage.
Mein Lieblingsfach … weiß ich gar
nicht. Was war denn dein Lieblingsfach?
Oder dein Hassfach? Na, ich habe gerade
darüber gesprochen, dass ich Mathe erst
ganz lange nicht mochte und dann mochte,
dadurch, dass der Lehrer dann ganz toll war.
Das ist gut. Ja, ich habe Mathe,
ich fand Mathe immer schrecklich,
aber war trotzdem gut dadrin. Deswegen war es für
mich, glaube ich, angenehmer als für andere Leute,
die es schrecklich fanden und auch noch dann … ja,
aber mein Lieblingsfach war eigentlich Geschichte,
was ich dann auch studiert habe, weil ich
das so interessant fand in der Schule. Wir
hatten auch einen guten Lehrer, aber
dann, in der Uni habe ich es auch
noch gemacht und heutzutage ist es, bin ich
gar nicht mehr so ein großer Geschichtsfan.
Ja. Gute Überleitung, wir haben mehrere Fragen
bekommen zum Studium in Deutschland. Agonzalez
fragt: "Stimmt es, dass das Studium in Deutschland
entspannter ist als in anderen Ländern?"
Ja. Nein, das …
Wir beantworten jetzt alle Fragen
nur noch mit "Ja" oder "Nein".
Das hängt natürlich davon ab, aber ich muss sagen,
dass ich auch noch zu einer Zeit studiert habe,
als es in Deutschland keinen Bachelor und
Master gab. Ich weiß, dass es heute stressiger
ist mit diesem internationalen Bachelor-
und Master-System. Da ist das, glaube ich,
ein bisschen ähnlich in den meisten Ländern.
Und es, ansonsten hängt es natürlich stark vom
Fach ab. Also ich weiß, dass ich damals in meinem
Geschichtsstudium ziemlich viel Freizeit hatte,
ziemlich viel Flexibilität und auch sehr viel
Zeit hatte für andere Dinge. Zum Beispiel bin
ich jedes Jahr vier oder fünf Monate
gereist, habe an Projekten gearbeitet.
Und das war alles in Ordnung, aber meine Freunde
zum Beispiel, die Elektrotechnik studiert haben,
Ingenieurwissenschaften, Medizin, die haben
eigentlich die ganzen Ferien damit verbracht,
zu lernen. Also, die hatten
überhaupt nicht so viel Zeit.
Ja, das beantwortet eigentlich
auch schon die Frage von Sakshii:
"Wie sieht das Studentenleben in Deutschland aus?"
Kommt total auf den Studiengang an und die Uni.
Also bei mir war es damals so eine gute Balance
zwischen lernen, arbeiten und Party, aber …
Ah ja? Du hast so, warst so ein Partytyp, Manuel?
Ich habe damals eine Wohnung gehabt in
Kiel, die … das war die Party-Wohnung,
weil die so total abgeschirmt war. Ich
war nämlich quasi … also da war, über mir
war nichts mehr — das war so ein ganz absurdes
Gebäude — und links und rechts und unten war ich
auch gut abgeschirmt. Und wir haben richtig laute
Partys bei mir gefeiert, und zwar ziemlich oft.
Echt? Ich dachte … also heutzutage machst du,
bist du ja eher nicht so der Typ, der
zu Hause große Partys veranstaltet.
Das stimmt, ja, aber das kommt
vielleicht nach der Pandemie.
Okay, das sehe ich als Einladung.
Ja, dann haben wir ein paar Fragen
bekommen, die so um das Thema Geld gehen:
"Was sind die versteckten Kosten, wenn
man in Deutschland lebt?" Hidden Costs.
Ja, diese Frage fand ich sehr interessant,
denn ich habe das schon selber erlebt in
anderen Ländern, in denen Deutsch gelernt
wird mit diesem Ziel oder diesem Wunsch,
nach Deutschland zu kommen und in Deutschland zu
arbeiten. Und ich denke, gerade in den Ländern,
wo die, ja, die Einkommensunterschiede und auch
die Währungen sehr unterschiedlich stark sind,
da gibt es auch große Unterschiede und auch ein
paar Vorurteile, also. In Deutschland verdient
man natürlich mehr als in Vietnam im Vergleich für
einen, auch für … ja, in fast den meisten Berufen
wahrscheinlich. Aber man muss auch eben darauf
achten, dass es in Deutschland auch größere Kosten
gibt. Also man kann in Deutschland wahrscheinlich
nicht für zweihundert Euro im Monat Miete zahlen,
sondern es ist richtig teuer. Es kommt drauf
an, in welcher Stadt man ist. Wenn man auf
dem Dorf ist, ist es billiger, und in der Stadt
gibt es dann eben auch noch … oder sagen wir,
überall gibt es dann auch noch andere Kosten, die
man nicht mit bedenkt. Zum Beispiel habe ich mir
da mal aufgeschrieben die Mietnebenkosten, also,
Kosten, die noch zu einer, die zu einer Wohnung
dazugehören, die man aber oft nicht mitzählt.
Man sieht dann zum Beispiel, die Wohnung kostet
sechshundert Euro, aber dann muss man selber
noch draufzahlen. Man muss die Heizung zahlen,
Strom zahlen, Internet. Man muss sogar
für das Fernsehen in Deutschland zahlen,
es sei denn, man ist Student, dann kann
man davon ausgeschlossen werden. Also,
da gibt es einiges. Auch die Krankenversicherung
zum Beispiel ist etwas, das habe ich auch gehört
von Leuten, die nach Deutschland kommen, die
gesagt haben: "Toll, in Deutschland gibt es
Krankenversicherung umsonst", aber sie ist
nicht umsonst, sondern sie ist nur Pflicht.
Sie ist verpflichtend, ja. (Ja,
richtig.) Kommst nicht drum herum,
aber man muss sie schon bezahlen, ja.
Und gerade, wenn man dann so wechselt,
wenn man mit dem Studium fertig ist:
Als Student ist das super billig, aber wenn
man dann plötzlich sich selbstständig meldet,
aber noch gar keinen richtigen Job hat,
weil man verdient vielleicht auch immer
noch nur siebenhundert, achthundert Euro und
die Krankenversicherung kostet dann plötzlich
zweihundert oder dreihundert oder sogar
mehr, dann kann das schon schnell eine,
so eine versteckte Kost… Kosten sein,
die man vielleicht nicht mit bedacht hat.
Ja. Auch noch eine hohe, ja, auch noch zu den
Kosten zählen ja die Steuern, die man bezahlen
muss, und dazu hat uns Albert gefragt: "Wie
viel Steuern zahlt man denn in Deutschland?"
Es gibt natürlich ganz viele verschiedene Arten
von Steuern für individuelle Menschen und für
Unternehmen, aber ich habe auch mal kurz die
wichtigsten recherchiert. Also, Mehrwertsteuer,
die kennt man ja. Immer, wenn man was kauft, ist
da schon in Deutschland die Mehrwertsteuer mit
drin. Also man muss nicht im Supermarkt rechnen
wie zum Beispiel in den USA, aber es sind immer
neunzehn Prozent Mehrwertsteuer, fast zwanzig
Prozent. Einkommensteuer — also das ist die
Steuer, die man bezahlt, wenn man Geld verdient
— ist abhängig davon, wie viel man verdient und
irgendwo so zwischen vierzehn und fünfundvierzig
Prozent. Also, wenn man viel verdient, zahlt man
fast die Hälfte seines Gehaltes wieder in Steuern
an den Staat. Kirchensteuer haben wir gerade
drüber geredet vor Kurzem: Das ist, wenn man in
der katholischen oder evangelischen Kirche ist,
zahlt man acht oder neun Prozent dessen, was
man an Einkommensteuer zahlt. Ist kompliziert,
aber kommt auch noch dazu. Und dann gibt es noch
Steuern, wenn man zum Beispiel mit Aktien handelt
und so weiter. Was es in Deutschland nicht gibt
seit 790, seit 1997, ist eine Vermögensteuer.
Also, man zahlt dafür, dass man einfach reich
ist, zahlt man in Deutschland keine Steuern.
Das ist ein guter Punkt, dass du das
gesagt hast. Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es das vor 1997 gab, ehrlich
gesagt, aber das ist jetzt etwas,
was zum Beispiel jetzt aktuell im
Wahlkampf — in Deutschland ist ja,
am 26. September gibt es Wahlen — diskutiert wird.
Es gibt einige Parteien, vor allem die Linke,
die möchte gerne Vermögensteuer wieder einführen,
und das, ja, ist ein interessantes Thema. Also im
Vergleich zu einigen Ländern gibt es, glaube
ich, in Deutschland viel Steuern oder, Manuel?
Ja. Also es gibt viele Länder, wo die
Steuern niedriger sind, zum Beispiel
unsere Nachbarn in der Schweiz, da ist, in den
meisten Gegenden zahlt man zum Beispiel viel
weniger Einkommensteuer, aber klar. Gibt
auch Länder, wo es höher ist, keine Frage.
Deswegen gehen Deutsche, die sehr
reich sind, gerne ins Ausland,
weil sie dort weniger zahlen. Aber ich muss
sagen, ich bin persönlich ein Fan von Steuern,
denn ich denke, dass wir in Deutschland ja auch
eine gute Infrastruktur haben, und das vergisst
man manchmal. Wir reden zwar oft darüber, was
nicht funktioniert, wie zum Beispiel Internet,
aber grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass mit
den Steuern alles bezahlt wird, also, ein
halbwegs gutes Bildungssystem, ein halbwegs gutes
Gesundheitssystem. Und ich mag das eigentlich.
Und auch ein soziales Netz. Niemand muss in
Deutschland so richtig Angst haben, dass er
gar nicht mehr essen kann oder gar nicht mehr
leben kann. Und klar gibt es Armut in Deutschland,
aber es gibt ein gewisses Netz, in das man
fallen kann. Und das ist schon sehr gut.
Ja. (Ja.) Leben in Deutschland.
So. (Oh.) Oh, habe ich das falsche … ach so,
Steuererklärung. Oh Gott,
wollen wir darüber reden?
Ja, also eine Steuererklärung, da gibt es
unterschiedliche Sachen. Bardo hat gefragt, zum
Thema Steuererklärung wollte er gerne mehr wissen.
Vielleicht machen wir da noch mal einen eigenen
Podcast zum Thema Steuern, Manuel. Wäre das was?
(Klar.) Und dann laden wir mal einen Experten ein,
jemand, der sich damit besser auskennt als wir.
Also, ja, ich habe einen Steuerberater, muss ich
sagen, Gott sei Dank. Das ist … aber ich habe es
auch früher selber gemacht und es geht, aber ich
kann mir vorstellen, wenn man neu in Deutschland
ist, dann ist das sehr verwirrend, wie man eine
Steuererklärung machen muss. Mittlerweile gibt es
aber viele neue Tools, habe ich gehört. Es gibt
Apps, es gibt Online-Services, die dir helfen.
Und das ist vielleicht ein bisschen angenehmer.
Pablo möchte wissen: "Warum haben die Fenster
von Wohnungen in Deutschland weder Vorhänge
noch Rollläden?" Er ist scheinbar in
eine Wohnung gezogen und dachte sich:
"Wieso kann ich das Fenster nicht verdunkeln?"
Das ist interessant, dass das … ja, aber ich
glaube, das gehört insgesamt zu diesem Thema.
Wenn man in Deutschland in eine Wohnung
zieht, dann ist da gar nichts drin. Und
in vielen anderen Ländern ist es normal, dass
man eine Küche hat, dass man manchmal sogar
alle Möbel hat. Und in Deutschland ist das
wirklich so, dass man sich … also, vor allem,
wenn man direkt einziehen möchte, muss man
das planen, dass man alles mitbringt. Und
die Vorhänge sind tatsächlich, ich habe schon
bei einigen Umzügen dann auch erst mal ein paar
Tage ohne Vorhänge gelebt. Das kann schon nervig
sein. Muss man selber dran machen, ne, Manuel?
Richtig. Also Rollläden, die ja so von
außen sind, die hat man bei einem Neubau
vielleicht schon installiert, aber bei
einem Altbau ist einfach gar nichts. Also,
bei älteren Gebäuden ist einfach gar nichts
und dann muss man selber bohren und eine
Leiste oben anbringen und da kommt dann der
Vorhang dran. Das gehört zur Erfahrung dazu.
Das muss man können.
Ich habe mal bei einem Umzug mit
Nora — die war auch schon mal hier
im Podcast — sehr lange versucht, ein Loch
in die Wand zu bekommen für die Vorhänge.
Und nach sehr langer Zeit und nachdem wir
schon einen Spezialbohrer gekauft hatten,
ist uns aufgefallen, dass wir in
die falsche Richtung gebohrt haben.
Was? Wie geht das denn?
Also wir haben quasi, du kannst ja umstellen,
ob der rein- oder rausbohrt. Und wir hatten
das auf die f… also wir haben quasi in die
falsche Richtung gebohrt. Also es ist uns
auch sehr peinlich im Nachhinein, aber wir hatten
damals noch nicht viel handwerkliche Erfahrung.
Krass, aber … ja, so was, könnte auch sein,
dass ich das nicht merke, ehrlich gesagt.
So was lernt man dann.
Manuel, wollen wir ein paar
Live-Fragen beantworten?
Unbedingt.
Hier, das ist eine Frage, die kannst
nur du beantworten, wenn überhaupt.
"Funktioniert ein analoger Fernseher
noch in Deutschland?", will Nick wissen.
Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube … selbst,
also, selbst Flachbildschirme, die noch
nicht irgendwie so eine bestimmte Digitaltechnik
unterstützen, funktionieren auch schon nicht mehr.
Es wurde alles auf, irgendwie verschlüsselt.
Ich kenne mich auch nicht so genau damit aus,
aber ich glaube, wenn man so ganz
alte Fernseher hat, wird es schwierig.
Das, ja, mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht sagen. Aber
ich finde die Frage von Gustavo sehr interessant,
liebe Grüße an Gustavo. "Wie stellt ihr euch
Deutschland in zwanzig Jahren vor?" Manuel,
haben wir dann endlich schnelles Internet?
Das wäre mein Traum. Sehr gutes Internet
und gute Infrastruktur, multikulturell,
viel mehr, als es das bis jetzt ist. Viel
grüner und nachhaltiger und nicht mehr
auf Pump leben. Also im Moment ist es ja
so, dass wir mehr Ressourcen verbrauchen,
als die Erde wieder generieren kann. Das
wären, glaube ich, meine drei größten Wünsche.
Ja, denkst du, dass Deutschland … wir haben ja
die Tage darüber gesprochen, dass es jetzt dieses
Urteil gab am Bundesverfassungsgericht, und das
Urteil besagte, dass die Bundesregierung noch
nicht genug tut für den Klimaschutz. Und
ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, ich meine,
wenn man sich überlegt, was sich alles in den
letzten zehn Jahren verändert hat, ne? Also,
vor zehn Jahren war Klimaschutz überhaupt noch
… also es war auf der Agenda, aber niemand hat
das so ernst genommen, weil es auch nicht
so einen krassen öffentlichen Druck gab,
den gibt es jetzt. Und ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass in zehn Jahren … dass
das einfach noch stärker ist, oder würde es
mir erhoffen, dass dann die jungen Menschen,
die jetzt zu Fridays for Future gehen oder
die das zumindest ideell unterstützen, dann
auch vielleicht in verantwortlichen Positionen
sitzen und dann … also dann es einfach viel mehr
an Selbstverständnis ist, dass wir Sachen
ändern müssen. Ja, das wäre meine Hoffnung.
Das muss passieren. Ja.
Ja, ich habe noch, ich habe noch eine Live-Frage
hier, Manuel, oder hast du noch eine von unserer …
Nee, schieß los.
Von unserer Instagram-Liste?
Habe ich auch, aber mach du mal.
Wir haben sehr viele Fragen. Erst mal danke
an euch, dass ihr so viele Fragen stellt,
und das macht uns auch Spaß, die zu beantworten,
sofern das technisch hier funktioniert. Und zwar
kam eine Frage von Shaleen, die ein bisschen
zu dem passt, worüber wir eben gesprochen
haben. Sie fragt: "Warum ist die Zahlung der
Rundfunkgebühr Pflicht?" Und das finde ich
ein interessantes Thema, weil früher habe ich
das auch nicht so genau verstanden. Man zahlt
in Deutschland mittlerweile … wie viel ist
das, pro Monat siebzehn oder achtzehn Euro?
Ja, ungefähr, ein bisschen mehr,
glaube ich, sogar, ja. Irgendwie so.
Und das ist die sogenannte Rundfunkgebühr. Das
heißt, von diesem Geld werden öffentlich… werden
öffentliche Fernsehsender, Radio und mittlerweile
auch YouTube-Programme bezahlt. Wenn ihr solche
Programme kennt vielleicht wie "STRG_F",
"Y-Kollektiv", die machen viele Reportagen.
Ich glaube, "MrWissen2go" gehört auch dazu.
Also viel Bildungs… viele Bildungsprogramme,
die in Deutschland auf YouTube laufen, werden
tatsächlich mitfinanziert von diesen Gebühren. Und
viele Leute sind dagegen. Es war früher, vor allem
früher sehr unpopulär, weil die, diese Eintreibung
der Gebühren auch manchmal sehr unfreundlich
war, aber eigentlich, von der Idee her finde
ich das ein sehr gutes System, ein … der, das aus
der Zeit, eigentlich aus der Nachkriegszeit kam,
wo man gesagt hat, man möchte in Deutschland
das nie wieder zulassen, dass es möglich ist,
die staatlichen Sender irgendwie zu kontrollieren,
von einer Partei, von einer Regierung, und man
möchte ein unabhängiges Rundfunksystem haben. Und
damals hat man das aufgebaut nach dem Vorbild der
BBC und ich glaube, die Engländer waren da auch
sehr stark beteiligt. Und deswegen haben wir heute
eigentlich einen, ja, sehr guten öffentlichen
und unabhängigen Rundfunk. Und man hat gesagt,
man will das eben nicht durch die Steuern
zahlen, damit der Staat das nicht bestimmt,
weil die Steuern bekommt ja der Staat. Der Staat
muss dann entscheiden: "Bauen wir neue Schulen
oder neue Straßen oder ein Atomkraftwerk?"
Und damit das nicht in Konkurrenz steht,
hat man gesagt, die Leute zahlen das direkt und
der Staat hat quasi damit nichts zu tun. Und ich
glaube, ja, wenn das einfach eine Steuer wäre,
würden das viele Leute nicht merken und einfach
zahlen. Dadurch, dass das extra bezahlt wird,
haben viele Leute so ein negatives Gefühl. Es
ist eigentlich so wie eine Netflix-Pflicht
sozusagen, ne? Aber … ja, wie siehst du das?
Ja, ich habe nichts hinzuzufügen, außer, dass ich
noch Easy German Podcast Episode 26 dazu empfehle.
Ist schon lange her, aber da haben wir auch schon
über das Thema ausführlich gesprochen und genau,
da gibt es noch ein paar mehr Infos. Ja.
(Guter Tipp.) Cari. (Ja?) Andrés möchte
wissen: "Ist es wirklich so kalt
in Deutschland, wie alle sagen?"
Ja. Ja, kommt darauf an, wo man herkommt. Wenn
man aus Norwegen kommt, ist es in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich ganz okay, aber ich muss
auch sagen, ja, haben wir ja schon öfters im
Podcast drüber geredet. Diesen Winter, wo ich zum
ersten Mal nur monatelang am Stück in Berlin war,
ohne reisen … ja, es ist irgendwie, es ist
schon kalt oder? Es ist nicht furchtbar,
man kann auch lernen, bei minus zehn Grad
draußen spazieren zu gehen und das zu genießen,
aber ist schon schöner, wenn es
dreißig ist, finde ich persönlich.
Man muss natürlich dazu auch sagen, dass Berlin
einen ausgesprochen harten Winter hat. Ich glaube,
die sonnigste Stadt Deutschlands ist Freiburg, die
hat die meisten Sonnentage. Also alle, die sich
nach Sonne sehnen, sollten nach Freiburg ziehen.
Sowieso eine wunderschöne Studentenstadt. Cari …
Guter Tipp, Manuel. Toll!
Zieh einfach nach Freiburg.
Problem gelöst. Amber möchte wissen:
"Was ist ein guter Witz auf Deutsch
oder über Deutschland?" Ich habe einen.
Ich lache jetzt schon, Manuel.
Beim letzten Mal haben meine Witze
nicht so gut funktioniert, als wir
eine Sendung mit Witzen gemacht haben, aber mein
Lieblingswitz auf und über Deutschland geht so:
Wie viele Leute … nee, wie viele Deutsche
braucht man, um eine Glühbirne zu wechseln?
Zehn.
Einen. Wir sind nicht sehr witzig und sehr
effizient. So landen meine Witze immer bei dir.
Man hätte auch sagen können zehn, so, einer, der
das Formular vorbereitet, einer, der die Risiken
recherchiert, einer, der eine Versicherung
abschließt, der andere, der die Leiter hält,
der Zweite, der die Leiter absichert noch
mal. Der Dritte guckt, ob kein Wind kommt.
Der Nächste beschwert sich bei den Nachbarn,
weil es ist Sonntag und es ist
eigentlich gar nicht erlaubt.
Richtig, richtig. Manuel, ich sehe gerade, wir
hatten ja auch Fragen an unser Team. Ich glaube,
die hast du am Anfang übersprungen. Kann das sein?
Das ist korrekt. Du warst ja nicht
da, ich war ja ohne Team hier.
Es tut mir sehr leid, Manuel. Und zwar gab
es eine Frage von J oder J, ich weiß nicht,
der Name war abgekürzt: "Können wir die
Hipsterbrille von Manuel anschauen und genießen
beim Live-Video? Wäre cool." Und ich muss sagen,
wir machen das jetzt schon. Liebe Leute, das ist
die neue Hipsterbrille von Manuel. Dazu würde ich
jetzt gerne ein paar Kommentare hören und sehen.
Okay, ich werde sie mir jetzt nicht live
anschauen. Später dann. (Ja.) Ja, Rachel …
Mir gefällt sie.
Danke schön! Rachel fragt: Wie wäre es,
wenn wir bitte jeden Tag einen Podcast
machen könnten? Falls ihr das nicht wisst,
wir machen dreimal pro Woche einen Podcast,
in der Regel dreißig Minuten, wir kommen gleich
zum Ende. Cari, jeden Tag? Was meinst du?
Jeden Tag wäre anstrengend, glaube ich. Also,
ich mag den Podcast sehr, aber ich glaube auch,
dass es schön ist, wenn der nicht jeden Tag
kommt, damit man sich darauf freut. Ich merke
das auch mit den Podcasts, die ich höre, dass
ich mich freue, auch bei YouTube. Ich weiß,
es gibt Kanäle, die jeden Tag was
machen, aber ich hätte nicht die Zeit,
das jeden Tag zu gucken. Und ich freue
mich mehr, wenn man sich Zeit nimmt,
etwas vorzubereiten, und ja. Besser … lieber
Qualität statt Quantität, ist meine Meinung.
Ich sehe es genauso. Ich glaube, wir haben einen
ganz guten Sweet Spot gefunden, der für uns sehr
gut funktioniert und ja. Aber als Mitglied bekommt
ihr Bonus-Content. Wir reden nämlich nach der
Aufnahme, also, wenn sich die Aufnahme dem Ende
zuneigt, so wie jetzt, dann reden wir danach
immer noch so ein bisschen privat weiter und das
ist dann in dem Mitglieder-Feed noch mit drin.
Das ist ja eine top Überleitung, Manuel, denn
tatsächlich, manchmal reden wir so lange noch
nach dem Podcast, nach der Episode oder nach der
offiziellen Episode weiter, dass wir daraus noch
eine eigene Episode machen könnten, weil wir dann
erst richtig noch mal kontrovers diskutieren.
Manchmal. Manchmal sind es auch nur zwei Minuten.
Ja, stimmt. (Wenn du schnell …) Und man
hört … man hört unsere technischen Probleme.
So wie jetzt.
So wie heute. Ja, tut mir leid, dass wir ein
bisschen holprig in die Sendung gestartet sind,
weil ich ein technisches Problem hatte.
Es hat mich trotzdem sehr gefreut,
mit euch zu quatschen und
eure Fragen zu beantworten.
Mich auch. Es war trotzdem
total schön mit dir, Cari,
und wir hören uns übermorgen wieder. Bis dann!
Ciao, bis bald!
Ciao!